the gyro can experience I was really
impressed with the way Chuck handled
that loss did you see the way Chuck
talked about on Instagram he just
basically said you know hey man you know
you put yourself out there
you go out there you set goals you know
you you try and if you fail it doesn't
doesn't mean you quit you get back on
your horse and yeah and get right back
to it yeah I try not to be so judgey man
let go of all the hate and all the
[ __ ] press me too and I like Chuck
he's a good person I attract is if
he--if tito's are rather john john's
number one Chuck's number two so far as
light heavyweights great light
heavyweights he's he was the [ __ ] man
I mean it was when he defined the early
days of the UFC one of the things about
the UFC was like this crazy thing was
like cage fighting and here's this guy
with painted toenails and a mohawk and a
dead tattoo and he's just Merkin people
Merkin people they just like was like
the first big big star this sport to
transcend and go on to entourage and
have commercials
yeah those [ __ ] automotive commercial
it was like a rock star - I mean that
dude went ha where do you stand remember
that one interview that he did Hammer he
was on something he's an author drives
everything and he's like is doing
morning TVs like yeah I'd like to fight
the Hulk I wish she was real that great
I love that what the [ __ ] is that he was
clearly on cloud nine animal man like
legit where do you stand on letting
those whose responsibility is that the
guys like BJ Penn who keeps losing its
defined as like it's now guy like
Anderson Silva where do you stand on
letting those guys fight it's a very
good question but if you're Dana White
what do you do because at the end of the
day I only do the Commission should go I
yeah man he passed the [ __ ] physical
so we gotta let him fight but at the end
of the day if they don't have a resource
or a job from the head man if Dana calls
BJ or Chuck just like you didn't chuck
he's like I'm not giving you a venue to
find that it's not happening so I what I
wonder at what point if you're Dana
let's say you're dating at what point do
you tell these guys stop fighting
because I feel like for Anderson
although I don't remember him that way
the new generations remember him for
being this guy for BJ the new generation
only knows him as losing we know them as
one of the greats
hmm so I feel like I owe you
say you can't fight anymore I don't know
BJ is capable of competing the level
that he's competing at right now when
he's losing to these guys I don't know
if he is because it doesn't seem like
he's capable of it weight loss what six
in a row yeah and if I look at the BJ
that I saw against Ryan Hall up until
the time he gets leg locked he looks
[ __ ] great laughter that happened
fast though bro
no I know I'm with you I'm saying he
looks like he's fit he looks like he's
in shape he looks like he's a top
fighter but he almost needs to fight a
young guy coming up so we could see when
he fights Clay Guida or you fight
someone like that it's almost losing
yeah in Ryan Hall he's losing I feel
like I don't know he's not who we used
to be no obviously you know not but I
don't even know where his head's I feel
like if I'm if I'm Dana I'm going hey
man I'm doing you guys a solid you can't
fight her anymore and now they might go
on to other organizations but it's not
the UFC so they can go on there and
compete but you're not gonna tarnish
your legacy at the highest level here in
the UFC not under my watch no so I I
couldn't do it I would like I'll never
pick against BJ I would never pick
against Randy Couture I just I don't
have it in me so when BJ fights like
I'll take BJ cuz I refuse to pick
against and that's how much I respect
them but at some point I'm not gonna do
it and I don't obviously Dana can either
could you be like a dude no more we're
done well I have to be friends with him
my girl's friends with you yeah you know
I mean when when Yaya Rodriguez 360
roundhouse kicked him in the face that
should have been the end I mean that
well that was you saw that and compared
to BJ when BJ beats on Chirk like you're
looking at a this is a severely
different fighter whose job is telling
family and friends no one's job you know
here's the thing man we can't let the
fighter decide well what is I don't
think he should be competing at the
highest level of the sport but if he
still wants to compete like who's to say
he can't
who's to say he can't go to a small
organization and fight for them who's to
say I mean he's not a choice is it just
he's not gettin spark'd out you know I
mean he's still conscious he's not yeah
I know he's getting beat but he's not
getting crushed nope and not in all the
fights at least I mean the Ryan Hall one
is probably the most
Brian house can't hear anyone's knee
after oh yeah oh yeah if he gets a give
him but he's gonna do that to your knee
well he's a phenomenal grappler and his
super super intelligent guy too but that
was probably the the kindest way for him
to lose just get tapped real quick
rather than just get a black belt beat
up like Fraser did to him yeah I know
but I guess it may be again the
Commission they have a tough job cuz
like physically we can't see into his
brain but physically he's passing all
the tests like who he's dropping to tell
Bernard Hopkins not take that last fight
when he got not got the [ __ ] ring
whose job was to tell Roy Jones don't go
to rush and get knocked out yeah I don't
worry that's so old it repeats itself
over these guys what they got that's
what makes these stories so great when
they're in their prime and you're
watching when they come up and so
special but it's also what makes this
sport so [ __ ] heartbreaking did you
know who does do that the NFL in the NBA
they tell you no they tell you now
that's it and it's very black but that's
because someone has the opposition and
they're not about nostalgia they're
about who does the best job in that
position shouldn't the UFC be that way
but it's not that the UFC doesn't know
who does the best job in that position
until they set you up with somebody when
they see over and over and over again
then we've salt but it gives me six but
the argument is he's not getting crushed
he's not gettin spark'd out not getting
knocked out he's just not as good as he
used to be no it's not a good argument
but he's not he's not as good as you
used to be yeah and I'm not saying I'm
not arguing why he's still at the UFC in
his attempt I don't know why the because
he's still a draw maybe yeah that's a
good question because because right now
in the respect is it out of respect like
what is it what he's done for the game
he's earned the right to go out on his
own note but the stakes are so high in
fighting it's different than basketball
I don't know whose job it's and I don't
have the answer and I wish I did I don't
know it's it's the most heartbreaking
thing in sports I think I agree and I
think with BJ if he would have found and
I don't know BJ well enough but if you
would have found a passion like I did
with stand-up or podcasting or something
else you probably would have been out
never come back
maybe but the thrill of what makes BJ
yeah I mean he's a multiple time world
champion
the thrill of bj when he was in his
prime is probably indescribable like
what brings Nate Diaz vacuum there's
money in the bank what's gonna bring
Connor back yeah it's not money yeah
because guys were born fighters they're
natural-born fighter sees what they do
and that's that's what makes them feel
alive so I don't know you have the
excitement the thrill the [ __ ] I mean
and look we're all gonna die so I when
people say you should look out for their
health well then we should stop fighting
all together correct and no please
football yeah I stopped drinking and no
more driving yeah driving is dangerous
go walking everywhere if we just walk
and people get in accidents walking
they'll we find a bump into each other
it's a big deal that would be cool yeah
I mean it's there's a real argument for
that right like this is a give a small
window the experience its life do you
want but yeah with a guy like BJ Penn
the reality is there should probably be
a number of fights that you lose in the
UFC where you just get cut you speak
three was it a signed in paper thing no
but man when you've lost two which I did
that third one Joe Silva would tell your
management he told my manager like me
Lex McManus know when this one
you know it's spray over we know he
would say that he go with we're giving
him one more and he knew that was like
that was just shot if you lost you were
done even if you want but by decision
that when it cut you
[Applause]